Okay. If I tell you about Donald Trump's constant
confused speech, but don't tell you when it's
happening to Democrats, I would be a hypocrite.
I respect you too much to play that game.
So I must tell you today, I must, that Joe
Biden speeches are increasingly confused and
odd. Yesterday during a campaign speech in
South Carolina, which will vote on Saturday,
dough Biden claimed to be a candidate for
the United States Senate rather than the presidency.
And he also referred to voting for the other
Biden. If you don't like what you see, which
maybe was a joke or not. I mean, I genuinely
can't tell. When I look at this clip, I'm
worried about Joe Biden just like I'm worried
about Donald Trump. I'm not playing political
games with this. When I see something, I say
something. So let's look at the clips, which
are truly odd. This is from South Carolina
yesterday
and you're the ones that sent Barack Obama
the presidency, and I have a simple proposition
here. I'm here to ask you for your help. Where
I come from. You don't get far unless you
ask. My name's Joe Biden, I'm a democratic
candidate for the United States Senate. Look
me over if you're like, we see help out and
not both of the other by give me a look though.
Okay, that's all I really got to say to you.
I'm about to,
this is so strange that it's actually hard
to understand exactly what Joe Biden is saying
here, but he says, I'm Joe Biden running for
U S Senate. If you like what you see, help
out. If not vote for the other Biden. That's
what I'm hearing. Let's look at it one more
time.
And you're the ones that sent Barack Obama
the presidency and I have a simple proposition
here. I'm here to ask you for your help. Where
I come from. You don't get far unless you
ask. My name's Joe Biden. I'm a democratic
candidate for the United States Senate. Look
me over if you're like, we see help out. If
not both of the other by give me a look though.
Okay. That's all I really got to say to you.
I'm about,
I just don't know. I mean, what do you, what
do you make of this? I get, uh, lots of emails
of when this stuff happens, saying this is
just sad and Joe Biden shouldn't have run.
I get some emails from people who say, this
is clearly stress-related, not cognitive decline.
I don't know how you could really know one
way or the other at this point, just from
these videos. A couple of people wrote to
me about this and said, David, this is Joe
Biden's stutter. Now. I don't know about that.
Stuttering is nothing to make fun of. I know
stutterers and I don't know that stuttering
would cause someone who's running for president
to say, I'm running for Senate. I just don't
think that that has anything to do with a
stutter. I'm glad to be corrected if I'm wrong.
Joe Biden has had a stutter his entire life.
If you look at videos of him from 2012 when
he was running circles around Paul Ryan, when
debating him, the VP debate, you see a night
and day difference. If you look even earlier
in Joe Biden's career, the difference is even
more pronounced. So none of this stuff is
funny to me when Trump does it, when it happens
to Biden, it's concerning cognitive decline.
If that's what's going on is not a joke. It's
not funny. It's a medical condition. And just
as importantly, if we are selecting someone
to be president, which we are, whether it's
Trump or Biden or Bernie or whoever, we want
to be sure that the candidate has their full
faculties available to them. The job is extremely
demanding. It's physically demanding. It's
emotionally stressful every single day. I
mean, okay. I guess if you're Trump and you
just tweet and watch Fox news, maybe it's
not every day a important decisions riding
on what you do.
Um, Trump opting out out of that on a lot
of days, but in principle, every single day,
a lot is riding on the cognitive abilities
of the president of the United States. So
I don't know what's going on. It's weird.
We have more and more clips of this just like
we have more and more clips of Donald Trump
behaving oddly. And uh, I want to hear from
you what you think while we're talking about
South Carolina. Um, I will mention tonight
there's a debate in South Carolina. We'll
be covering it live on Saturdays, the South
Carolina primary. And let's take a look at
the polls. Joe Biden is still leading in South
Carolina in an average of recent polls leading
every individual poll except from one 11 days
ago where Bernie had tied Joe Biden in South
Carolina. We've been talking about South Carolina
sort of as the place where Tom Stire could
grab some delegates and he's right on the
brink of that 15% viability threshold.
Tom Stier polling 14.7 average in recent polls
as high as 20 as low as seven and no matter
what happens Saturday in South Carolina, I
do expect everybody who's in right now to
stay through super Tuesday. I don't know when
you have three days, really two full days
between the Saturday South Carolina primary
and Tuesday super Tuesday primaries in many,
many States. I don't know of any reason to
get out after Saturday before seeing what
happens on Tuesday, but I would not be totally
shocked if you see some exits after Tuesday
depending on the results. Tom Stire, if he
ends up with no delegates in South Carolina
nor in any other state, I assume Stier will
be out by midnight on Tuesday night. Tool
C, I mean, listen tools, he should've been
out a while ago. She doesn't have a path to
a single delegate. Maybe if again, she ends
up with zero delegates after super Tuesday,
maybe tool C will get out.
Amy Klobuchar, if she does really poorly on
Tuesday, maybe she would look at getting out.
Although she was putting a lot of energy into
California and maybe it's conceivable she
could pull something out there. So join me
tonight for the last debate before the South
Carolina primary and is it actually, it might
be the last debate before super Tuesday unless
they're squeezing in one more on, on Sunday
or Monday. Uh, we will be live at 7:15 PM
Eastern time on YouTube tuition, Facebook,
then Twitch alone for the entire debate. Join
me tonight and make sure you're following
the show on Instagram for more coverage of
the 2020 primary
at David Patton show on Instagram. While you're
there, follow me at David dot Pacman on Instagram
as well,